bonsoir et bienvenue ravi de vous
retrouver pour cette nouvelle saison de
savour garde en direct vous connaissez
la formule un invité fil rouge à mes
côtés chaque soir et c'est vous le
premier grand témoin de la saison
sachaillou bonsoir et merci d'être là à
vous présider la commission des lois à
l'Assemblée vous avez marqué la rentrée
politique avec cette tribune
transpartisane publiée dans Libération
pour la régularisation des sans-papiers
qui travaillent dans les métiers en
tension vers l'avenir dans le détail
immigration inflation et budget trois
sujets d'actualité sur lesquels on
reviendra dans la deuxième partie mais
on commence ce soir par le drame de
Lampedusa la plus massif et record de
migrants dans la petite île italienne
ravive la crise migratoire en Europe
l'Europe fustigée par Marine Le Pen et
au contraire appelé au secours par
Georgia Meloni la première ministre
italienne l'Europe problème ou solutions
face aux défis migratoires c'est notre
grand débat dans un tout petit instant
avec nos invités avant de retrouver tous
vos rendez-vous bien sûr à la fin de
cette émission Les Affranchis pour leur
partie prix ce soir l'économie avec
Olivier babot et l'international
Isabelle Lasserre et puis Bourbon
Express bien sûr l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée signé Elsa mondain Gava
voilà pour le programme on y va Sacha
Olivier
il revient de Rome avec un message de
fermeté renvoyé chez eux ceux qui n'ont
rien à faire en Europe voilà ce qu'a
déclaré Gérald Darmanin dans la capital
italienne après l'afflumacif de migrants
à Lampedusa alors au-delà des mots et
au-delà des formules chocs quels sont
les solutions concrètes d'urgence
humanitaires d'abord et de plus
longtemps l'Europe est-elle condamnée à
l'impuissance face au défi migratoires
bonsoir Patrick Stéphanie merci d'être
avec nous en direct ce soir vous êtes
conseiller d'État vous êtes un grand
spécialiste des questions migratoires
votre dernier ouvrage immigration ces
réalités qu'on nous cache chez Robert
Laffont et vous avez dirigé plusieurs
campagnes présidentielles la dernière en
date c'est celle de Valérie Pécresse
pour les républicains en 2022 bonsoir
Edwige Diaz merci d'être là vous êtes
député rassemblement national de Gironde
bonsoir Damien carême ravi de vous
accueillir sur ce plateau vous êtes
débuté écologiste européen et ancien
maire de Grande-Synthe dans le Nord
important parce que cette ville a été
confrontée à l'arrivée de milliers de
réfugiés on s'en souvient notamment en
2015 2016 enfin bonsoir Pascal Brice
bienvenue vous présider la Fédération
des acteurs de la solidarité et vous
êtes ancien directeur de l'OFPRA
l'Office français de protection des
réfugiés et des apatrides et vous plaît
pour un accueil organisé et maîtriser
des Migros vous nous en direz plus
évidemment vous êtes partis prenant plus
que jamais sachez oublier à ce débat
mais d'abord l'effet les images
Lampedusa un concentré des problèmes
migratoires de l'Europe c'est avec
Stéphane blackowski le chrono de Blacko
tout de suite
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir Myriam bonsoir
à toutes J'ai très heureuse de vous
retrouver pour cette nouvelle saison
alors si je commence par cette photo
vous avez vous dire à ce pauvre Blacko
n'est pas tout à fait rentrer de
vacances et ben si parce que cette île
c'est le cœur de l'actualité c'est
Lampedusa plus précisément la plage de
lapins qui est régulièrement avec lassée
parmi les 10 plus belles plages du monde
sur les sites de voyage sauf évidemment
les images qu'on a vu récemment à la de
l'actualité était bien différente je
vous en montrer une qui évoque toutes
celles qu'on ne peut pas en a montré
d'un seul coup je vous rappelle les
chiffres 10 000 migrants sont arrivés en
l'espace d'une semaine sur une île qui
en temps normal
accueille 6500 habitants donc pas
quasiment le double de la population
habituelle donc pour Georgia mélony qui
est à la tête du gouvernement italien
c'est un échec assez cuisant parce que
l'argument fort de sa campagne
électorale l'an dernier c'était cette
solution qu'elle proposait un blocage
naval pour empêcher les migrants
d'accoster sur les côtes italiens
d'ailleurs elle avait un peu mis cette
promesse en œuvre
au mois de novembre vous souvenez
qu'elle avait empêché l'accostage du
Ocean Viking et ça avait créé des
tensions avec la France il y avait 230
migrants à bord et bien là dis-moi plus
tard on assiste un revirement complet
puisque Georgian Meloni reconnaît que
l'Italie a elle seule ne peut pas faire
face à cette afflux soudain et massif de
migrants donc elle est plus question de
faire qu'avec les seuls et dans les
convaincue et elle le dit que la
solution passe nécessairement au niveau
européen d'ailleurs il y a quelque chose
qui traduit très bien ce changement de
position c'est que alors qu'il y avait
des tensions avec la Commission on voit
ici la présidente d'un lion et bien il y
a eu une réconciliation mélodie dit
parle d'une seule voix maintenant avec
la patronne de la commission pour dire
que la solution ne se trouvera que au
niveau de l'unité européenne alors en
France tout le monde ne considère pas
que ça soit une preuve de sagesse cette
idée de recourir à l'unité européenne au
contraire certains trouvent que c'est de
la faiblesse je vous donne l'exemple
évidemment de du RN qui est le c'est à
dire ça Sébastien Chenu est déçu mais
alors déçu déçu déçu déception absolue
par ce revirement de mélodie parce que
du côté de Marine Le Pen on ne change
pas la conviction reste la même la
France doit retrouver sa souveraineté
sur la question de l'immigration pour
l'écouter c'était hier soir sur TF1
c'est à nous nation de décider qui entre
et qui se maintient sans notre
territoire la Commission européenne
ne doit pas s'attribuer des pouvoirs qui
doivent rester aux nations parce que il
en va de leurs droits fondamentaux alors
évidemment quand on est dans
l'opposition il y a un avantage c'est
qu'on peut proposer des solutions
simples à des problèmes très complexes
en revanche quand elle nous gouvernement
ça vient beaucoup plus compliqué d'un
seul coup on attend des actes et surtout
des résultats donc celui qui est en
première ligne on l'a compris c'est
notre mise de l'Intérieur Gérald
Darmanin et donc il a immédiatement pris
une position où l'on le mot clé c'est la
fermeté vous voyez il disait hier il
faut absolument il insister sur le
renvoi nécessaire des migrants qui
n'avaient pas leur place en Europe mais
est-ce que tout le monde est vraiment
sur cette ligne du gouvernement disons
que Olivier Véran présente les choses un
peu différemment lui il insiste surtout
sur l'obligation qu'on a d'accueillir au
moins une partie de ces migrants donc on
imagine que le débat sur la proposition
le projet de loi sur l'immigration va
être assez animée au sein de majorité
nous ce soir on est là pour se poser la
question suivante est-ce que l'Europe
est le problème où est-ce que c'est la
solution pour faire face à la pub
migrants il y a 9 mois de débats qui se
prépare puisque les élections sont le
prévu le 9 juin mais on peut commencer
déjà on y va merci beaucoup pour cette
présentation Stéphane daskowski on va
parler du pacte migratoire asile qui est
en cours au fond de de changement de
discussion il est quasiment ficelé au
niveau des des chefs d'État dans dans
une deuxième partie mais il y a
l'urgence c'est 10000 migrants ils sont
là si vous étiez aux affaires Patrick
Stéphanie pour la France comment vous
aideriez l'Italie à gérer cette
situation d'abord je voudrais rappeler
que
c'est à l'Italie comme à chaque État
membre que revient la responsabilité de
contrôler sa frontière extérieure c'est
pas l'Union européenne qui est en charge
du contrôle des frontières extérieurs de
l'Union européenne c'est chaque État
membre donc c'est une responsabilité de
l'Italie elle peut être aidé dans
l'accomplissement de cette mission par
l'Union européenne et Darmanin déjà
c'est engagé pour la France il y a
d'ailleurs une agence européenne qui
s'appelle Frontex qui peut venir en aide
aux États membres mais encore faut-il
que les États membres le demandent alors
la Grèce a résolu ce problème elle l'a
résolu à Lesbos dans une île qui est à
un ou deux mailles des côtes Turcs en
créant un centre d'accueil moderne avec
un hôpital à l'intérieur du centre avec
une école à l'intérieur du centre
j'invite tous les participants à ce
débat s'ils n'ont pas fait aller visiter
ce centre on va voir d'ailleurs la carte
de l'arrivée là aussi
et les migrants qui arrivent de Turquie
ou d'autres pays et qui débarquent à
Lesbos ils sont accueillis dans ce
centre ils y restent aussi longtemps que
le nécessite l'instruction de leur
demande d'asile ou de leur demande de
titre de séjour et ensuite s'ils sont
des bouteilles la grande c'est l'Italie
qui n'a pas fait le travail c'est ce que
vous dites l'Italie en effet mis du
temps à faire le travail à la des
circonstances atténuantes l'île de
Lampedusa est une toute petite île 20 km
mètres carrés ça nous a été rappelé en
face de la Tunisie mais bon c'est loin
en tout cas
c'est pas facile à Lampedusa de faire ce
qui a été fait à lisbos en revanche dans
les ports de Sicile ou dans les ports de
l'Italie continental on doit pouvoir
s'organiser pour faire ce qui a été fait
à Lisbonne et pour faire ce qu'on fait
tous les jours aujourd'hui en France
dans nos aéroports parce que l'asile à
la frontière la procédure d'asile à la
frontière elle remonte à des années et
des années moi j'étais sous directeur
des étrangers au ministères de
l'Intérieur entre 88 et 90 je verrai
quotidiennement la procédure d'asile à
la frontière elle a donc plus de 40 ans
elle fonctionne de manière satisfaisante
les décisions sont prises je parle sous
le contrôle d'un ancien directeur
général de l'OFPRA sont prises par le
ministre de l'intérieur mais sur avis
conforme de l'offre donc en fait c'est
l'OFPRA qui prend la décision mais qui
prend la décision rapidement et dans des
conditions qui font que le migrant ne
pénètre pas sur le territoire de l'Union
européenne
on n'a pas statué sur sa demande mais ce
défi là migratoire réel et je fais
circuler la parole tout de suite est-ce
que vous considérez que c'est à
l'échelon européenne qu'il convient de
le gérer parce que c'est le plus
efficace ou pas pour bien comprendre on
n'a absolument besoin de coopération
entre les pays européens très bien
Pascal Brice l'Italie dans cette affaire
à une part de responsabilité directe
l'Italie
tous les gouvernements européens et
l'Union moi je partage le constat et la
proposition de Monsieur Stéphanie il se
trouve que je l'ai mise en œuvre avec
les équipes de Lovecraft vers 2015-2016
dans des ports espagnols italiens maltek
confrontés à la même situation moi ce
que je voudrais dire ici c'est qu'à mes
yeux ce qui se passe à Lampedusa n'est
pas l'illustration d'une subersion de
l'Europe on parle effectivement d'une
île de 6000 habitants 11000 personnes
dans une semaine donc c'est vrai que ça
donne cette sensation là qui est réelle
pour les habitants de 199 bateaux partis
de Tunisie avec des garde-côtes dont on
peut s'estimer un peu de 340 millions de
personnes avec un million probable
d'arrivés mais donc ça dépend
l'illustration du super Sion mais en
revanche c'est l'illustration à mes yeux
d'un renoncement
européen maîtriser
européennes et je partage ce que dit
Monsieur Stéphanie parce que la solution
elle existe je l'ai compliqué à titre
expérimental si j'ose dire effectivement
des centres fermés à l'arrivée en Europe
dont on parle je vais pas rentrer dans
la dans la technique mais
de rétention ce sont des centres se
devrait être parce que si vous voulez
moins ce que je ce qui paraît
insupportable c'est que après 2015 près
de dix années après rien n'a été fait
alors à chaque fois des gens se
précipitent instrumentalise font le
montre les muscles mais enfin comment
n'a-t-on pas mis en place ces
dispositifs qui font que lorsque les
gens arrivent sans refermer parce que
l'accueil l'accueil indispensable on va
pas laisser les gens crever en
Méditerranée on a besoin de cela pour
notre économie mais dis-toi être
maîtrisé
c'est un abandon et moi je demande à ce
qu'a enfin on mette en place ces
solutions qui existent abandon
renoncement de l'Europe des États à
mettre en place ces fameux centre pour
au fond accueillir et trier parce que
c'est
c'est quoi alors décidé de qui a droit à
la demande d'asile aux frontières
extérieures de l'Europe en Europe on
examine les demandes d'asile ce sont les
Européens qui financent qui aident les
Italiens les Grecs les Espagnols et
celles et ceux qui relèvent du droit
d'Asie ce que dit Monsieur Darmanin il a
raison
le premier enseignement c'est que je
sais pas si c'est l'Europe la solution
mais en tout cas tous ceux qui se place
en dehors de l'Europe en dehors des
solutions européennes ont faux je vous
donne deux exemples pour ça très clair
les Anglais les anglais sont sortis de
l'Europe pour reprendre le contrôle tech
back control résultats en 2022 record
d'immigration en Angleterre 600 000
entrées pour donner une idée on est à
320 000 entrées sur le territoire
français avec les titres qu'on délire ça
donne une illustration deuxième
illustration madame Meloni qui a fait
toute sa campagne en disant l'Europe
c'est un problème en réalité madame
Meloni au premier première difficulté au
premier afflux de migrants à lampéduza
qu'est-ce qu'elle fait elle appelle au
secours l'Europe ça c'est la première
chose deuxième chose choses
effectivement on a du retard on a du
retard sur le
packs
qui rentrent effectivement on les amène
vers les centres dont parler à la fois
Monsieur Stéphanie et Monsieur Brice
dans ces centres il donne y compris
leurs empreintes pour qu'on sache où
est-ce qu'il rentre ensuite on fait une
queue de répartition et tous les États
qui acceptent de prendre une partie de
ces personnes pour peu qu'ils soient
éligibles à l'asile ça n'est pas le cas
pour tout le monde
ont les aide européennes ce qui ne
l'accepte pas non plus d'être
européennes et puis ensuite on organise
collectivement la reconduite de pousser
la réforme du pacte l'immigration qui
est en cours sauf que on vous répondez
pas à la question du renoncement et de
l'abandon pourquoi parce qu'on a mis
deux ans parce qu'on a mis deux ans à
faire adopter cette musée Parlement
européen c'est aussi parce qu'on a pensé
et de mon point de vue c'était une
erreur qu'on pouvait installer ces
centres d'accueil et c'est la
construction des demandes d'asile dans
les pays d'origine ou en tout cas dans
les pays transit et notamment dans les
pays du Maghreb c'est la solution qui
avait été évoquée par l'Union européenne
dans les années 2018-2019 on faisait
fausse route on faisait fausse route la
France ne le fait pas à Calais pour les
migrants qui désignent c'est ce que vous
proposez le contrôle de l'asile dans les
pays sources de départ ou de transit
pour le dire vite par exemple à
Lampedusa le ministre dit 60% viennent
de Guinée de Gambie et de Côte d'Ivoire
comment comment on fait concrètement
vous proposer quoi des demandes au
consulat dans les ambassades comment
comment vous si vous êtes élu vous
faites ça oui déjà moi je pense que la
question migratoire
c'est un problème qui n'a pas été traité
depuis très longtemps Marine Le Pen
c'était rendu en 2011 à Lampedusa déjà
pour signer pour tirer la sonnette
d'alarme et 12 ans après rien ne s'est
produit donc la situation que nous
subissons actuellement elle était
prévisible et personne n'a voulu écouter
les alertes du rassemblement national
d'accueil d'examens des demandes d'asile
aux frontières extérieures de l'Europe
en Europe c'est juste dire en fait en
Italie non pas dans les pays de départ
moi qu'est-ce que vous répondez à ça je
pense qu'il y a une complémentarité et
une accumulation de propositions à
apporter déjà je pense que au niveau des
frontières elles doivent être doubles il
faut en effet que front que frontext
gère les frontières de l'Union
européenne mais c'est la police
ce qui est paradoxal c'est qu'en fait
aujourd'hui vous avez les frontières
européennes qui sont censés être gardées
par une Union européenne qui est
immigrationiste donc là en fait il y a
un premier paradoxe donc dès lors que
l'Union européenne appliquera une
politique visant à lutter résolument
contre l'immigration des gens n'aura
réglé une partie du problème
jusqu'au terminer sur du coup mais mes
deux jambes après compris il faut bien
sûr que la gestion des frontières relève
aussi de la souveraineté nationale c'est
vrai que ça fait on n'a jamais consulté
les Français est-ce qu'il voulait plus
ou moins d'immigration tous les sondages
indiquent que les Français veulent moins
d'immigration or la politique menée par
le gouvernement vise à accueillir
davantage d'immigration donc pour vous
l'Europe n'est pas la solution vous
voulez reprendre le contrôle des
frontières nationales ça veut dire quoi
concrètement s'en sortir des traités en
fait vous ne sortez pas des traités ça
vous n'êtes plus sur le frexit c'est
vrai vous voulez rester dans Schengen
mais en même temps reprendre le contrôle
national oui mais en fait moi je trouve
que la politique migratoire relève de la
compétence souveraine des états et donc
à partir du moment où les Français ne
veulent plus qu'on a qu'on accueille
autant d'immigration ne veulent plus
qu'on subventionne les ONG dont on peut
remettre en question le jeu un petit peu
trouble pour certaines à partir du
moment où les Français ne veulent plus
qu'on soigne gratuitement autant de
clandestins je pense qu'il faut écouter
les Français en tout cas nous on
rassemblement national c'est ce que nous
proposons et je pense en effet que pour
gérer cette crise migratoire donc il y a
la question des doubles frontières de de
renvoyer chez eux chez elle les
personnes c'est-à-dire nous les
secourons en mer pas de caricature nous
les droits d'asile vous ne le supprimer
pas absolument pas vous accueillez les
demandeurs d'asile oui mais en fait
c'est que nous nous quand ils sont
primés persécutés dans leur pays parce
que le problème en France aujourd'hui
c'est que vous avez un certain nombre de
déboutés du droit d'asile qui reste en
France et Monsieur Darmanin détient tous
les records en matière d'inexécution des
aucutés f donc la question est question
qui était le territoire pour ça que il y
a une complémentarité des mesures à
mettre en oeuvre et pour ça il faut du
courage politique et pardon de le dire
mais monsieur Macron ne l'a pas Damien
carême votre analyse de ce qui se passe
sur cette petite île italienne y a-t-il
un manque de solidarité déjà ce à ce
stade des autres pays de l'Union
européenne il se trouve que Gérald
Darmanin est sur TF1 en même temps que
nous il s'apprête peut-être à faire des
annonces on voulait communiquera
qu'est-ce que vous attendez du ministre
de l'Intérieur
que il respecte ses engagements les
engagements de relocalisation par
exemple la France prend des engagements
qu'elle ne qu'elle ne respectent pas il
y a un an on avait pris l'engagement de
relocaliser c'est-à-dire de ramener
justement sur ces opérations de
sauvetage en mer au nom de la solidarité
humaine ou uniquement la question des
demandeurs d'asile éligibles qui ont une
chance d'obtenir leur titre plus on
l'examine pas ces qu'on les relocalise
c'est-à-dire il débarquent en Italie en
Grèce ou ailleurs et on les on se
répartit la charge de l'examen de la
demande d'asile parce que qu'est-ce qui
est derrière tout ça c'est la faillite
du Règlement Dublin le premier alors
première raison règlement de tublin
règlement européen qui dit que c'est le
premier pays d'entrée qui est chargé de
l'analyse de la demande d'asile des
personnes qui font la demande d'asile en
Europe donc ils arrivent en Grèce ils
arrivent en Italie ils arrivent en
Espagne et ces pays sont complètement
submergés par les personnes qui arrivent
le temps de l'examen de la demande le
temps de la procédure d'appel le temps
de la procédure de retour s'il y a pas
l'octroi de l'asile donc voilà et il ne
s'en sortent pas enfin là-dessus il y a
une unanimité du Parlement européen du
Parlement européen pour reconnaître les
dysfonctionnements du système de Dublin
donc il y a possibilité de faire autre
chose c'est à dire qu'il soit enregistré
quand ils arrivent en Europe dans les
premiers pays mais quand la personne est
la discussion que nous avons aujourd'hui
dans la réforme
européen mais dans le pack il y a
beaucoup de textes il y a notamment le
règlement Dublin c'est de faire en sorte
que si la personne peut prouver qu'elle
a de la famille dans tel pays qu'elle a
passé des diplômes qu'elle s'est formée
là qu'elle maîtrise la langue de tel
pays qu'elle soit tout de suite envoyée
dans ce pays pour que ça soit ce pays
qui soit en charge d'examiner la demande
d'asile ça enlèvera cette pression qu'il
y a sur ce pays parce que là il y a un
interprèmment parce qu'il y a 7000 8000
personnes qui sont arrivées mais il y en
a 124000 depuis le début de l'année et
c'était passé complètement sous les
radars alors qu'il y en a eu 65000
l'année dernière alors
dès qu'on pourra on a un petit problème
technique on vous montrera un sujet qui
montre les nouvelles règles mais je vais
essayer de les résumer à gros trait
cette réforme du pacte d'Asie
l'immigration a été votée par les chefs
d'État 21 sur 27 pas les Polonais palé
hongrois militalie la beauté et on
attend maintenant le feu vert du
Parlement européen il dit quoi il dit
que les demandes d'asile doivent être
examinées cette fois-ci donc au pays de
première entrée et si les personnes sont
éligibles alors elles sont réparties par
un quota de relocalisation dans les pays
de l'Union européenne vous le voteriez
vous parlementaire européen c'est un
c'est une avancée par rapport à ce qui a
décrit Damien Carême
qui décide non adopter aussi un texte et
on est beaucoup de négociations avec le
Conseil on peut critiquer
à l'Assemblée
le problème c'est qu'il est toujours là
et que l'Union européenne s'est montré
jusqu'à maintenant incapable de le
remplacer par un système alternatif
opérationnel donc pour l'instant les
régies par Dublin et dans ce cadre là il
faut absolument je rappelle encore une
fois je permets d'insister je le je le
redis à Madame Diaz mais je le dis aussi
aux autres participants à ce débat c'est
chaque État membre qui a la
responsabilité du contrôle de sa
frontière extérieure donc le principe de
souveraineté des États membres dans le
contrôle de leurs frontière extérieure
il est inscrit ça reste comme ça
frontext ne pourrait pas devenir le
gardien européen des frontières
extérieures de l'Europe en texte en
assistant très clairs soutenir l'action
d'un État membre ça demande mais le
principe de souveraineté il est au cœur
des textes européens et il faut que le
contrôle il faut que l'instruction des
demandes d'asile c'est ce que les
ministres ont décidé le 8 juin et ça a
été repris ensuite par les chefs d'État
il faut que l'instruction des demandes
d'asile se fasse à la frontière
extérieure de l'Union européenne ça
c'est un principe absolument c'est
exactement
pour l'instant ne l'a pas encore ratifié
et au fond la crise migratoire que nous
vivons à Lampedusa je suis désolé c'est
une sorte de parenthèse liée au fait que
pour l'instant les ministres se sont mis
d'accord sur un dispositif qui n'a pas
encore été ratifié par le Parlement et
qui n'ont que n'est pas en train et ben
on a retrouvé ce sujet signé Baptiste
garguichardier pour tout comprendre de
ces nouvelles règles en discussion une
révolution dit même Gérald Darmanin
explication regardez
la question migratoire mais la solidité
de l'Europe a rude épreuve alors qu'en
parallèle de nouveaux outils pour mieux
contrôler les frontières sont sur la
table je suis venu ici pour vous
rappeler à tout ce que l'immigration est
un défi européen et qu'elle nécessite
une réponse et une solution européenne
en juin dernier réforme du pactes
d'immigration une première depuis 10 ans
en ligne de mire
obliger les pays en première ligne comme
l'Italie la Grèce ou l'Espagne a examiné
en accéléré les demandes d'asile dans
des centres positionnés aux frontières
pour les migrants les moins éligibles
les autres États membres devront
accepter un quota ou fournir une
contribution financière à ces pays pour
financer le retour des migrants en cas
de demande refusée
mais la Pologne et la Hongrie sont
opposés à cet accord et refuse de payer
pour ses champs de rétention
contrairement à l'Italie de Georgia
mélonic elle souscrit à l'idée d'une
frontière plus dure nous présenterons le
règlement européen pour allonger au
maximum la détention et rapatrier ce qui
arrive régulièrement en Italie parce
qu'il ne s'agit pas seulement des
frontières de l'Italie mais aussi des
frontières de l'Europe
un dispositif qui nécessite de grands
moyens avant l'été
Ursula van der leion a proposé
d'augmenter de 15 milliards d'euros le
budget lié à la gestion migratoire pour
financer les infrastructures
les pour parler avec le Parlement
européen sont bel et bien en cours en
espérant la fumée blanche avec
l'adoption Dieu pacte en juin 2020
Pascal Brice on comprend qu'il faut
trouver encore un accord entre toutes
ces parties européennes il est il est
bon ce nouveau pacte ou pas oui mais
pardonnez-moi mais est-ce que vous
souvenez qu'il y a quoi deux ans
on a accueilli à côté de Marseille je
vais vous le dire je l'ai dit à Monsieur
combien j'étais en colère on met en
place ces centres ce centre fermé
d'accueil et tout le monde se tire
c'est-à-dire que en réalité rien n'a été
fait alors que la solution est là et
alors que l'on sait très bien ce que un
nous avons besoin d'accueillir parce que
moi je recommande à personne de se
regarder derrière une glace quand au fur
et à mesure du temps vit tranquillement
alors que les gens se grand Méditerranée
parce que notre économie en a besoin et
on sait combien ça travaille des
sociétés françaises combien il faut
maîtriser et organiser nous avons la
solution là que les gouvernements a
commencé par le gouvernement français
médecin en place que l'on vote ce
dispositif et qu'en fin on cesse de
d'instrumentaliser la moindre crise de
cette nature sur une île européenne et
qu'on apporte une solution on joue avec
le feu avec quelque chose qui est trop
sérieux pour ne pas passer à l'acte et
qu'enfin on apporte des réponses qui
soient la mesure des besoins de ce que
nous sommes et des besoins de notre
économie alors si on mettait en place ce
nouveau pacte les Français qui nous
regardent se disent est-ce que c'est
de Lampedusa cesserait est-ce que s'il y
avait ce donnant donnant au contraire
extérieur avec ses centres et les moyens
nécessaires de Frontex de l'Italie mais
aussi des relocalisations moyennant
sanctions parce que ça c'est aussi dans
les dans les réformes si vous
n'accueillez pas vous payez 20000 € par
refus de d'accueillir un migrant est-ce
que les problèmes disparaîtraient
pas de se déplacer ou devenir ou
traverser la Méditerranée parce que
l'Europe aurait adopté un texte mais
quand bien même n'importe quel pays
adopte n'importe quel texte ça
n'arrêtera pas l'immigration et
principalement l'immigration venue
d'Afrique qui aujourd'hui celle qui est
la plus présente en revanche ça le
permet et ça a été dit par différentes
personnes qui certes sont en désaccord
mais qui au fond disent des choses qui
sont quand même assez identiques c'est
que 1 ce que vous dites monsieur
Stéphanie est-ce que vous dites monsieur
carême y compris monsieur Brice c'est
que c'est un problème européen il y a
madame Diaz qui est pas d'accord avec ça
et on n'est pas d'accord avec Madame
Diaz parce que c'est ce que je vous
disais tout à l'heure tous ceux qui sont
sortis de la solutions européenne se
sont trompées et soit on l'immigration
record Angleterre soit soit font appel à
l'union européenne ensuite parce que
sur cette question de savoir
ensuite il y a de la modalité
c'est-à-dire d'abord dans la solution
commune en Europe on accepte de traiter
communément les demandes d'asile ensuite
et c'est bon où est-ce qu'on est prête à
la frontière extérieure de l'Union
européenne c'est les centres qui sont
proposés par la Commission européenne je
pense c'est une solution ou alors c'est
ce qu'on fait déjà à Lisbonne c'est ce
qui pourrait être fait
ou alors ou alors être la répartition
dans les pays d'ores et déjà c'est ce
que propose de Karen c'est la différence
aujourd'hui entre la Commission et le
Parlement en tout état de cause il faut
que yesss examen commun notamment les
forces de gauche veulent que les examens
d'asile restent dans les pays
les ensembles des pays et pas seulement
les pays d'arrivés de première arrivée
Méditerranée une partie de la droite une
fois qu'on a accepté que c'était
européen une fois qu'on a accepté qu'il
y avait un examen commun il faut qu'il
répartition commune et là pour le coup
c'est très répartition commune elle dit
il y a tous ceux qui n'ont pas vocation
à rester qu'on le reconduit et ce qu'on
a vocation accueillir parce qu'ils sont
éligibles à l'asile et l'égibles à la
protection alors dans ce cas là les pays
qui accueillent selon leur choix ont
l'argent mais tous ceux qui
n'accueillent pas et bien par définition
et à contrario n'ont pas l'argent et ça
c'est une solution de bon sens qui
devrait aussi nécessiter l'accélération
et l'adoption du pacte migration
financière lourde pour les pays qui
refusent d'accueillir parce que les
demandeurs éligibles c'est le principe
même de la solidarité
encore faut-il que les reconduites à la
frontière enfin les reconduites dans les
pays d'origine soit possible et ce qui
s'est passé à l'empe p12a interroge je
vais vous faire écouter Bruno Retailleau
va vous faire forcément réagir Patrick
Stéphanie c'est c'est le même parti il
s'interrogeait sur la possibilité de
départ massif depuis la Tunisie écoutez
c'était sur un terre ce matin
j'ai quand même un doute moi parce que
200 bateaux 199 très exactement bateau
en quelques jours qui partent de Tunisie
les garde-côtes Tunisiens n'ont pas pu
ne pas les voir donc quelque chose s'est
passé il y a eu un accord vous savez
avec des euros des millions d'euros à la
clé entre notamment l'Europe l'Italie et
puis la Tunisie mais quelque chose qui
n'est pas normal c'est passé vous
partagez cette interrogation
100 millions d'euros étaient perçus par
la Tunisie de l'Europe justement pour
garder cette frontière ça ne s'est pas
passé comme ça 197 190 bateaux plus de
490 bateaux qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
selon vous moi je pense que la
coopération avec les pays transit ou
avec les pays sources c'est absolument
nécessaire mais qu'elle est pas
suffisante on peut pas se reposer sur
l'attitude des pays tiers pour pratiquer
une politique souveraine de maîtrise de
nos frontières et de pilotage de
l'immigration alors peut-être que Bruno
Retailleau a raison on a celui qui avait
eu en Tunisie
des réactions extrêmement hostiles du
gouvernement et partant de la population
à l'égard des populations d'Afrique
subsaharienne
des réactions d'ailleurs assez
condamnable dans leur principe mais
enfin bon c'est comme ça que ça s'est
passé mais c'est pas le sujet le sujet
c'est le sujet du retour le question que
vous posez c'est le retour une fois que
les intéressés sont déboutés dans les
centres d'instruction des demandes et là
on se rend compte que l'immigration ça
relève aussi de la diplomatie on doit
discuter avec les pays d'origine qui
doivent délivrer des laisser passer
consulaires alors on peut trouver ça
injuste on peut trouver ça stupide on
peut même avec les pays du Maghreb
aujourd'hui pour les obtenir mais c'est
l'expression de leur souveraineté à eux
donc il faut il faut accepter ce
principe donc ça veut dire qu'il faut
avoir de bonnes relations avec les pays
sources quelqu'un me faisait remarquer
aujourd'hui que par exemple la France a
de bonnes relations avec le Sénégal avec
la Côte d'Ivoire avec la Gambie avec un
certain nombre de ces pays et à
l'inverse on a du mal actuellement
éloigné les migrants en provenance de
Tunisie et à l'inverse l'Italie semble
avoir de meilleures relations que nous
avec la Tunisie mais il y a un outil qui
s'appelle Frontex qui a été inventé pour
organiser des vols de retour concertés
entre les pays européens et on pourrait
tout à fait imaginer que Frontex
organise des vols au départ de Paris
avec des migrants interpellés en Italie
mais qui est repartirait vers le Sénégal
et la Côte d'Ivoire avec laquelle la
France a de bonne relation et obtient
facilement des laisser passer
consulaires et qu’un versement fasse
partir de Rome vers la Tunisie des
migrants interpellés en France là aussi
nous avons besoin de coopération
européenne et c'est le rôle de Frontex
Pascal Brice je pense que monsieur
retaillod a raison parce que parmi les
conséquences de cette absence de réponse
organisée et maîtriser il y a des gens
qui continuent à mourir en Méditerranée
il y a cette ce poison qui s'instille
dans la société européenne sur la
question de la place des étrangers et
puis il y a tout benoîtement qu'à tour
de rôle l'Europe se met dans la main des
milices libyennes du roi du Maroc de la
junt algérienne du président tunisien du
président turc quand c'est pas Poutine
et lucachenko donc voyez bien que même
pour notre liberté notre souveraineté
européen et de français il faut mettre
en place ces solutions de maîtrise vous
savez
encore une fois moi ce que j'aurais
c'est qu'on passe aux actes et qu'on
arrête de faire des discours de montre
les muscles lorsque je suis parti
avec les équipes de l'offre aux
alentours de 2016-2017 mettre en place
la solution de Monsieur Stéphanie
descente d'instructions de la demande
d'asile avec d'autres agents européennes
d'instruction la demande d'asile je me
suis permis de dire à l'époque à
l'exécutif que ce serait pas mal que le
mythe de l'Intérieur français de
l'époque dont je tiens tirait le nom
organise avec ses homologues européens
la reconduite de celles et ceux que nous
allions et que nous avons débuté dans
ces centres rien a été fait on a fait
les grands discours alors
qu'effectivement monsieur stéphanie a
raison il faut là que dans ce cadre-là
d'abord on accueille bien comme il faut
dans de bonnes conditions les personnes
qui arrivent on les accueille non
seulement pour l'asile mais moi j'y
ajouterai pour la migration de travail
organisée
contrôler et ensemble
à la très belle tribune qui a signé
monsieur Houllier et certains de ses
collègues on organise la pression sur
les pays d'origine pour le retour mais
allons-y arrêtons parce que vous disiez
madame mais pourquoi il se passe rien
mais moi je vais vous dire à mon avis
pourquoi il se passe rien parce que on
est sur des espèces de débat politique
en instrumentalisent d'un côté en
instrumentalisent de l'autre donc moi je
vous dis des solutions existent et c'est
trop grave pour qu'on continue à ne rien
faire à mettre de l'huile sur le feu et
vice sur le sur le reportage que vous
avez diffusé pour vous dire que moi je
dénonce la duplicité de ceux qui
instrumentalisent ces drames humains
pour faire avancer leur agenda
immigrationniste et européiste et c'est
exactement ce que Madame Van derlen est
venue faire à l'empedusa dans votre
portage vous avez indiqué qu'elle avait
dégagé un budget pour faire de la
gestion de la crise migratoire moi je
pense au contraire qu'elle devrait
débloquer des budgets pour faire de la
dissuasion en matière d'immigration et
et je condamne d'autant plus fermement
le chantage qui est fait au peuple
européen je le rappelle en France les
Français sont opposés les sanctions
financières en cas de refus d'accueil
les Français sont majoritairement
opposés à la politique migratoire qui
est menée actuellement et alors qu'on
vient de dire sur ce plateau que la
question de l'immigration était une
relevée de notre souveraineté là on a
une commission européenne qui est non
élue qui est technocratique qui fait les
parlementaires et lui de toute façon
pas tout à fait parce que la Commission
européenne est très puissante et donc là
en fait on vient dire bah du coup si
vous prenez pas votre part vous aurez
des sanctions financières et en plus les
sanctions sont considérables donc moi ce
que je veux dire c'est qu'en fait vous
avez le commerce
à ce renoncement le titre résignation
vous avez un parti comme le
rassemblement national qui est déterminé
qui fait preuve de courage et qui pourra
enfin répondre aux aspirations des
Français et je pense que les élections
européennes du 9 juin prochain seront un
bon test pour mesurer d'autres que ce
thème central dans la campagne
après le pouvoir d'achat après l'hôpital
public après les retraites etc
la question du retour on le voit elle
est très compliqué la question du retour
est compliquée qu'il y a des questions
première question c'est l'accueil et
c'est le respect des droits humains
c'est ça qui m'intéresse moi c'est
comment on respecte chaque personne qui
arrive en Europe et comment
effectivement il y a des droits il y a
des devoirs et comment si jamais on
n'accepte pas l'asile si l'asile est
refusé en Europe comment on conduit des
gens mais on arrête les politiques
européennes qui mettent sur la route les
gens aussi l'accord pourquoi il y en a
tant de tunisien qui arrive aux gens
enfin de gens qui étaient en Tunisie qui
arrive bah c'est l'accord de juillet où
on signe sous prétexte d'avoir un accord
économique avec la Tunisie qui a besoin
de l'argent de l'Europe pour débloquer
des fonds du FMI pour relancer son pays
économiquement on a sorti ça à une
politique migratoire où l'on lui demande
de faire le jeu de l'Europe et de
repousser tous les migrants qui sont
parfois dans le pays installé et qui
travaillent depuis des années
sur ces pays
on vous donne ça si vous si vous
appliquez nos politiques à nous même
chose avec le Sénégal on a une politique
un accord de pêche
UE Sénégal ou les bateaux les gros
bateaux européens vont payer toute la
ressource halieutique au Sénégal et donc
les pêcheurs sénégalais ils ont ils ont
plus de quoi bouffer et ben ils vont
chercher du boulot ailleurs et il y en a
60 qui meurent pour aller sur une île au
Cap Vert dans un bateau il y a 15 jours
derrière personne n'en parle mais c'est
aussi la résultante de nos politiques
européennes on maintient autre exemple
on achète toutes les électricité
renouvelable de la Namibie dans ce pays
10% de la population accède à l'énergie
on les met dans les installent dans la
précarité pour satisfaire forcément que
les gens de développement qui n'a pas
été aide au développement peut-être que
c'est plus c'est un gros mot je sais pas
vous allez me dire mais on l'a pas on
l'a pas évoqué c'est ce que vous nous
dites en filigrane est-ce que est-ce
qu'on est suffisamment présent sur ce
terrain là pour terminer c'est d'abord
il faut se méfier parce que il y a un
certain nombre d'études qui montrent que
que les programmes d'aide au
développement génère de la migration
génère plutôt de la migration parce
qu'ils permettent l'élévation du niveau
de vie d'une partie de la population
l'accès à ce que j'appellerai une forme
de classement moyenne et cette classe
moyenne va ensuite elle a les moyens de
se payer des passeurs ou en tout cas ce
qu'il faut ce qu'il faut ce dont il faut
s'acquitter pour venir en Europe donc il
faut se méfier ceci dit une fois qu'on a
dit ça je partage une partie de ce que
vous avez dit Monsieur une partie tant
qu'on n'aura pas en Afrique une
agriculture qui nourrira la population
africaine tant qu'on n'aura pas une
industrie africaine qui fournira des
emplois aux Africains et bien on aura
toujours une pression migratoire sur
l'Europe sur ce point je suis d'accord
et ben on va s'arrêter sur cette note de
consensus sur un sujet pareil rares sont
les débats aussi sereins et point
d'accord de différents bords politiques
vous restez avec moi Sacha Houlier merci
à vous dans une dizaine de minutes elle
est partie pris de nos affranchis ce
soir un nouveau venu l'économie avec
Olivier Babeau qui déclaré sa flamme à
un impôt bien français j'ai nommé la TVA
on va retrouver Isabelle Lasserre pour
l'international qu'est-il arrivé au
dictateur tchétchène Ramzan Kadirov et
puis d'un Bourbon Express Elsa mon
dingava de quoi nous parlez-vous ce soir
je vous parle du point commun entre
landreauge et l'écriture inclusive c'est
le menu de la niche du rassemblement
national en octobre à tout de suite les
amis mais d'abord on va parler de vous
sachez Olivier vous êtes le député qui a
marqué la rentrée politique avec cette
tribune publiée dans Libération sur le
projet de loi immigration 10 jours après
quels résultats le coût de pression sur
le gouvernement a-t-il fonctionné voit
ça dans l'invitation signée ce soir par
Marco 1er
si on vous invite à chaoulier c'est
parce que l'aile gauche de la majorité
se rebiffe et vous en êtes le porte-voix
en Une de Libération vous réclamez dans
une tribune avec d'autres personnalités
de la nupesse la régularisation des
sans-papiers dans les métiers en tension
l'initiative agace dans votre propre
camp et j'ai peur qu'on perde finalement
le message clé qu'on veut faire passer
qui est celui de la fermeté en
commençant par parler de régularisation
Sacha Houlier vous avez su vous rendre
un contournable aujourd'hui président de
la puissante commission des lois à
l’assemblée votre ascension est
fulgurante étudiant à l'esprit
contestataire vous multipliez les
actions durant vos études grève et
blocage contre le Contrat Première
Embauche contre aussi la réforme des
universités le message qui a été délivré
et qui a été bombé
surtout la rue Victor Hugo il est le
suivant c'est étudiant mobilisé contre
le lr.u contre la masterisation contre
les suppressions de poste d'abord
militant socialiste tendances
troscanienne le déclic s'étend 2015
Macron boy de la première heure vous
cofondez le Mouvement des Jeunes avec
Macron à seulement 28 ans vous entrez à
l'Assemblée nationale vous devenez le
plus jeune vice-président de
l'institution chers collègues quand je
mets au vote en amendement c'est un
amendement quand je me vois ton article
c'est un article
ambitieux proche du président à la fois
loyal et têtu voilà comment la presse
vous qualifie vous la voit parfois
dissonante de la majorité abstention sur
la loi sécurité globale opposition à
l'application stop covid sur ces
questions d'éthique il y a toujours une
liberté de vote une liberté de
conscience et finalement la capacité de
s'exprimer à titre totalement individuel
une âme de fronde ur mais pour quels
résultats la gauche exclut de voter le
projet de loi immigration la droite
menace avec une motion de censure de
quoi mettre la pagaille dans la majorité
alors Sacha houiller jusqu'où irez-vous
voilà réponse à shaoli vous allez
continuer à fonder jusqu'à l'adoption du
texte parce qu'en réalité ce qu'on a vu
on a vu des questions européennes sur
l'immigration et on a aussi des réponses
nationales il répondent nationales c'est
de lever des hypocrisies qu'est-ce qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui en France on a des
difficultés à ce que des personnes qui
commettent des actes de délinquance sur
le territoire ne soient pas expulsés
c'est le fait que elle ne se passe
systématiquement expulsable c'est
l'objet d'une des dispositions du projet
de loi
qui est radicalement à droite et qui
devrait pouvoir être défendu parce que
elle est admise par la droite elle est
soutenue par les Français mais vous avez
dit après vous aviez la garantie que la
partie sur les régularisations des
métiers en tension serait dans le texte
c'est sûr ça et donc j'en viens à cette
deuxième partie pour lequel je réitère
le fait que j'ai eu des garanties
qu'elle soit dans le texte qui est elle
radicalement à gauche qui revient à dire
tous ceux qui sont aujourd'hui dans les
cuisines françaises qui assure la
propreté des bureaux qui sont dans les
hôpitaux de médecins à aide-soignant
pour
faire passer ça c'est l'homme de la
situation en tout cas c'est le ministre
de l'intérieur qu'à la charge des
négociations et donc moi j'ai toute la
confiance sur le fait que on a travaillé
ensemble ce texte tous ces mesures sont
une nécessité et donc on doit les faire
adopter par rapport à pourquoi il faut
que ce soit dans la loi et pourquoi on
le fait pas par une mesure du
gouvernement le prendre et réglementaire
et bien parce que précisément
aujourd'hui on a une circulaire qui est
non contraignante que pour plein de
raisons on applique pas on applique mal
donc on n'a pas de résultats et donc des
personnes qui sont éligibles et qui
devraient avoir des papiers et qu'on
devrait laisser tranquille parce qu'elle
travaille pour le bien-être pays elle ne
les ont pas c'est pour ça qu'il faut une
méthode
ou rien sinon vous votreez contre on est
bien d'accord pour l'instant j'ai pas
besoin de faire ce genre de ménage vous
avez parlé de coups de pression au
départ je pense qu'on a un travail de
co-construction qui fait qu'on aboutit à
ce texte là et donc mon travail moi
c'est d'aller chercher l'adhésion de
certains partis politiques on a vu
Gérald Darmanin qui était aux
universités du groupe liotte moi aussi
j'ai beaucoup travaillé avec le groupe
yote on a eu des discussions quoi qu'on
en dise avec les rép y compris moi et
puis on a des discussions avec les
groupes de gauche et donc nécessairement
moi puisque j'ai peut-être plus indiqué
pour ce républicain parce que les lignes
rouges n'ont pas n'ont pas beaucoup
bougé pour pour bien comprendre
quels sont ces métiers en tension on
parle de la restauration de l'hôtel riz
on parle aussi de l'hôpital de la santé
mais on ne dit jamais combien est-ce que
vous avez une idée du nombre de
sans-papiers qui travaillent aujourd'hui
dans ces métiers là et est-ce que la loi
elle parle du stock c'est-à-dire c'est
sans papier qui sont déjà là qui
travaillent ou du flux c'est à dire ce
qui viendrait demain pour travailler
d'abord je vais être très clair c'est le
stock on parle aujourd'hui des gens qui
sont présents sur le territoire et donc
tous ceux qui évoquent l'idée d'un appel
d'air se trompe parce que précisément
c'est des gens qui travaillent déjà on
leur demande trois dans un 3 ans
d'ancienneté on leur demande huit mois
sur 24 et en plus c'est une mesure qui
est expérimentale et qui expirera au
bout de plusieurs années donc ça ça
c'est très clair charge à nous de la
reconduire c'est la fonctionner ensuite
normalement devrait avoir totalement
fonctionné on n'aurait pas besoin de la
Recon ensuite sur la question de combien
de personnes ça représente entre
a priori pas là-dessus entre quelques
milliers et quelques dizaines de
milliers mais je vais être très précis
on ne sait pas et j'aimerais bien savoir
et donc j'aimerais bien demander à la
direction générale des étrangers en
France qui me le disent le service du
ministère de l'Intérieur qui concernait
en tout cas contrairement à d'autres
pays qui le font l'Allemagne va
nationaliser on fait pas ça on
régularise on donne des cartes de séjour
pas la nationalité l'Allemagne va
nationaliser un million de personnes la
Wallonie va massivement régulariser
l'Italie de Jordy Amélie on a vu tout à
l'heure les difficultés malgré ça
Georgia Meloni dont on peut pas la
suspecter de sympathie gauchistes elle
va régulariser 400 000 travailleurs sans
papier dans son pays ça n'est pas
l'option du gouvernement de la
régularisation c'est bien on est bien
au-delà de 10 fois moins alors juste une
petite question sur le Medef moi je
m'étonne de sa discrétion je croyais que
c'était si important pour les chefs
d'entreprise de parvenir assez
régularisation rapidement écoutez c'est
un allié ou pas les chefs d'entreprise y
compris adhérents au MEDEF à la KPM à la
FFB dans tous les syndicats
professionnels ils sont peut-être
discrets encore que ils prennent la
parole dans les médias locaux il y en a
beaucoup qui ont répondu à l'appel que
j'ai lancé à l'appel que à relayé
Stéphane séjourné auprès des chaises et
en tout cas ils sont dans nos
permanences pour nous dire nos salariés
ne nous les enlevez pas voilà ceux qui
sont aujourd'hui dans nos entreprises et
qui nous permettent de faire tourner les
boutiques ne nous les retirez pas une
autre tactique parlementaire serait de
scinder le texte en deux un projet de
loi et précis un projet de loi sur les
régularisations mais qui en tension ça
vous irait peu importe le flacon pourvu
qu'on est livré on a on a des mesures
qui sont nécessaires qui sont
importantes et qui sont je répète
populaire parce que soutenu par la
population et donc si c'est un texte si
c'est deux textes y compris même s'il
faut avoir une 49-3 parce que le
Parlement ne veut pas prendre ses
responsabilités il faut ces dispositions
80% des Français sont d'accord avec les
expulsions des étrangers délinquants 60%
des Français sont d'accord pour
régulariser les travailleurs dans les
médias le passage en force sans vote
c'est ça
si les parlementaires à un moment donné
ne sont pas capables de de reconnaître
des mesures qui auront été intense
soutenus par la partie sans jamais avoir
été mis en place c'est Nicolas Sarkozy
qui avait supprimé à double peine c'est
la gauche qui n'a jamais légiférée sur
la régularisation dont je vous parle et
bien je pense que sur ce sujet il faut
que nous prenions les nôtres bon la
route est longue le texte arrive début
novembre au Sénat il y a eu pas mal de
rebondissements quelque chose me dit
qu'il y en aura sûrement d'autres
l'autre sujet sur lequel la majorité est
plus qu'attendue c'est le pouvoir
d'achat Bruno Le Maire a reçu les
distributeurs les pompistes qui vendent
de l'essence dans les stations services
revendre à perte vous croyez qu'ils vont
le faire vraiment je le pense d'autant
plus que ce sera permis de pas la loi ce
que je vais vous dire par rapport à ça
c'est que surtout tout ce qui est le
quotidien des Français dans les
dernières années dans les 12 derniers
mois il y a une action du gouvernement
sur le carburant il y a eu la remise à
la pompe aujourd'hui il y a la vente à
perte qui permet d'économiser jusqu'à 47
centimes d'euros 47 centimes vous sortez
d'où ce chiffre
qui nous a été transmise par le
gouvernement et a priori leur leur
logiciel qui permettent des simulations
sont plutôt exactes puisque c'est ceux
qui tu as envie de calculer 30 centimes
de réduction deuxième chose sur
l'électricité le gaz je veux quand même
rappeler que certes elle a augmenté pour
de nombreux Français et c'est douloureux
quand on regarde les factures en
revanche elle a été très largement
limitée cette augmentation par le
bouclier tarifaire y compris financé
parce qu'on a fait la taxe sur les super
profits finalement on a découvert ce que
c'était on a fait la taxe sur les super
profit elle a rapporté 26 milliards
d'euros et c'est C26 milliards d'euros
qui ont permis et bien que les Français
ne payent pas beaucoup plus cher et la
gaz électricité troisième chose sur les
prix de l'alimentaire vous souvenez
qu'il y a eu le trimestre anti-inflation
donc on a réussi à contenir les prix
maintenant les prix sont contenus à la
hausse donc ce qu'on fait ce qu'on veut
faire c'est faire une loi qui permet de
renégocier les prix pour qu'il soit
aujourd'hui à la baisse l'inflation qui
commence à stagner voir baisser les
Français ne le ressort pas je voudrais
vous montrer votre collègue Richard Amos
du MoDem qui lui propose sur les
questions des sens de revenir à ce qu'on
appelle la tcpe flottante et donc en
gros de baisser les taxes quand le baril
est bien augmente pourquoi pas
qu'est-ce que vous dites-vous le
Renaissance
publique c'est-à-dire que on fait pas
tourner la planche à billets et on
invente pas des ressources nouvelles et
donc ces ressources là elles sont utiles
à deux titres d'abord c'est des
ressources pour l'État pour garantir son
budget et ensuite surtout c'est faux
investir pour la transition écologique
on n'aura pas de voiture de voiture
nouvelle avec des primes à la conversion
on n'aura pas de logement rénovés on
n'aura pas de mesures incitatives pour
faire la transition écologique si on n'a
pas d'argent public j'entends que la
porte est fermée on verra parce que le
MoDem a beaucoup d'amendements notamment
dans le budget pour trouver de l'argent
notamment sur les plus riches on verra
ça vous restez avec moi sachez oublié
c'est l'heure d'accueillir nos
affranchis leur partie prix vont vous
faire réagir ou les accueille tout de
suite bienvenue les affranchis
l'économie avec Olivier babot président
de l'Institut sapiens ce qui rejoint la
bande des affranchis et qu'on est ravi
d'accueillir bonsoir Isabelle Lasserre
qu'on retrouve avec plaisir des pages
diplômes du Figaro installez-vous on
commence comme chaque soir par Bourbon
Express l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée
nous est consulter ce soir par Elsa mon
dingava bonsoir Elsa bonsoir comme c'est
un peu notre rentrée des classes ce soir
à savouregarde je vous parle d'une autre
rentrée des classes celle d'un groupe
parlementaire c'est sa deuxième rentrée
ici à l'Assemblée nationale sa bonne
résolution cette année c'est de se faire
des copains parce que les autres groupes
ne veulent pas vraiment jouer avec lui
je parle du rassemblement national qui
espère avoir trouvé et bien la solution
pour forcer ces petits camarades à
travailler avec lui ce matin je vous
explique c'était la conférence de presse
pour présenter les textes sélectionnés
pour leur niche parlementaire vous le
savez chaque groupe d'opposition dispose
d'une journée de 9 heures à minuit pour
inscrire à l'ordre du jour ses
propositions de loi 7 textes sont pour
l'instant inscrits par leur
rassemblement national soutenir les
femmes qui souffrent d'andrométriose
supprimer ou suspendre les allocations
familiales pour les parents d'enfants
criminels ou délinquants baisser les
factures énergétiques tant pour les
particuliers que pour les entreprises
l'interdiction de l'écriture inclusive
créer un complément de revenu garanti
par l'État pour les étudiants accorder
l'asile politique à Julien Assange le
contrôle des déclarations des minorités
étrangères alors évidemment ces textes
n'ont pas été choisis au hasard un des
objectifs du rassemblement national
c'est de couper le cordon sanitaire pour
que d'autres députés votent enfin leur
propositions et pour ça ils ont proposé
des textes un peu consensuels on pense
au premier qu'ils vont défendre celui
sur l'endométriose une maladie qui
touche une femme sur dix alors est-ce un
choix sincère ou un calcul politique on
a posé la question à Jean-Philippe
Tanguy
les autres groupes est-ce qu'il y a des
pièges là-dedans est-ce que vous voulez
forcer finalement les autres groupes à
faire ce qu'ils ne veulent absolument
pas faire voter vos textes mais c'est
pas un piège que tant le rassemblement
national nous propose des textes
d'intérêt général les Français tous les
sondages le montrent veulent le
dépassement des clivages et veulent que
les textes soient voter selon la
pertinence de leur objet et pas les
positions politiciennes qui n'ont aucun
intérêt donc ce sont nos adversaires qui
se mettent dans une situation absurde et
surtout contraire à l'esprit de leur
mandat et alors c'est pas un piège mais
ça y ressemble quand même pas mal pour
la majorité c'est même à traquenard non
oui bah le RN c'est faire de la
politique les autres groupes ont bien
senti le danger on commence à
s'organiser à réfléchir aux stratégies
alors chez vous côté Renaissance on a
connu des journées niches assez
douloureuses on va s'organiser Marie le
bec elle est députée des Yvelines elle
est vice-présidente du groupe c'est elle
qui est en charge de cette stratégie
contre les textes d'opposition la
stratégie pas encore arrêtée mais on
prépare d'ores et déjà les argumentaires
sur l'endométriose c'est compliqué de
voter contre comment vous allez faire
comment vous allez vous en sortir c'est
clairement un piège qu'il vous tende
alors il y a pas de stratégie qui a été
encore définie de la part de la majorité
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que sur
la question de l'endométriose le
précédent ministre de la Santé a eu
porté un plan donc on va défendre cette
ligne et par ailleurs c'est très bien de
faire des titres très tonitruents on le
voit dans toute la niche du
rassemblement national c'est parce que
vous faites un très beau titre que ça
fait un très bon texte à gauche aussi on
se un peu coincé là on est allé voir
clémentinottin la députin soumise à
laver défendu une proposition de
résolution sur l'endométriose et
pourtant et bien il ne votera pas
forcément le texte écoutez
Jean-Philippe Tanguy ce matin dit
personne n'est propriétaire des thèmes
ne soyez pas sectaire si vous êtes pour
défendre au mieux les femmes qui
souffrent d'endométriose voter notre
texte mais c'est encore une fois je
redis ce que j'ai à dire le problème
c'est que le texte est mal fichu le
deuxième c'est qu'il y a une opération
politique de l'extrême droite d'accord
qui veut faire croire qu'elle est du
côté des femmes alors que nous savons
pertinemment et toute l'histoire le
montre que ce camp politique a toujours
combattu l'émancipation des femmes elle
y reste encore trois semaines pour se
caler la niche du RN c'est le 12 octobre
on suivra ça de près c'est inconcevable
pour vous de voter pour un texte du RN
c'est quoi c'est tabou totalement quand
on veut jouer avec les autres on évite
de leur piquer leurs jouets voilà le la
santé a fait un plan sur ce sujet
mais la moto avait déposé une
proposition de résolution brutale
unanimité je pense que le rassemblement
national a fait une opération de
communication et ça s'arrêtera là
on enchaîne avec vous Olivier Olivier
babot en ces temps de fortination la TVA
n'a pas de bonne presse le RN Marine Le
Pen ne cesse de dire qu'il faut la
baisser notamment sur les carburants
pour faire baisser les prix à la pompe
et vous et ben c'est tout le contraire
c'est un éloge à la TVA que vous
proposez ce soir oui Myriam je suis
comme le saumon j'aime bien nager à
contre-courant et effectivement sur ce
coup-là je sens que je vais être un
petit peu seul à faire l'éloge de la TV
alors je parle bien de la taxe sur la
valeur ajoutée celle qui est à 20% à 10%
pour le taux réduit à 5,5 celles
évidemment que la ration nationale
aimerait supprimer pour les produits
première nécessités et 2,1 pour le taux
super réduit alors effectivement faire
un éloge de la TVA c'est un peu comme
faire je sais pas moi des sonnets au
formulaire CERFA ou une ode à l'URSSAF
évidemment ça paraît un petit peu un
petit peu bizarre mais essayons d'aller
un petit peu plus loin d'abord saluons
une invention française qui a tranquille
monde exactement comme le cinématographe
le braille le stéthoscope l'autocuiseur
ou le croque-monsieur la TVA est une
invention française et oui cocorico
c'est l'un de nos brillants
fonctionnaires le très regretté Maurice
Lauret qui avait le génie des impôts et
la TVA il faut le dire est un impôts
génial que le monde entier génial
vraiment génial parce qu'il a qualité il
a la qualité des bons impôts un bon
impôts il a un taux relativement faible
et surtout il a une assiette très très
large la plus large possible et
l'assiette de la TVA vous le savez c'est
formidable c'est là consommation et
c'est un grand avantage ça permet de
faire casquer les importations et ça
dans un pays qui est un très très fort
déficit qui ne cesse d'ailleurs de ce
s'agrandir faire payer la consommation
en particulier des importations c'est
extrêmement bien alors évidemment on
reproche beaucoup à la TVA son côté flat
tax c'est-à-dire le fait un petit peu
régressif d'être un petit peu plus lourd
pour les gens qui dépensent une partie
plus importante de leurs revenus
c'est-à-dire les gens plus modestes
alors on pourrait objecter un d'abord
que l'impôt sur le revenu et là pour
faire la part évidemment progressive
puisque 50% des gens ne le payent pas et
puis on peut dire aussi que en fait
l'épargne du point de vue économique
n'est que de la consommation différée
donc à la fin quand vous allez consommer
vous allez de toute façon payer toujours
ce taux bon je vous dis la TVA en fait
non seulement ça n'a pas formidable mais
en plus il faudrait l'augmenter alors là
j'ai bien entendu c'est pas le moment
Olivier non vous me verrez pas tous les
jours explique qu'il faut augmenter les
impôts mais là je trouve que c'est une
bonne idée alors pourquoi augmenter
quelque part pour pouvoir le baisser
ailleurs la TVA c'est la solution à
notre problème de financement de la
protection sociale qui pèse aujourd'hui
sur le travail on se souvient que
l'épithète social à la TVA avait pas
porté tout à fait chance en 2007
n'est-ce pas à la droite aux élections
législatives ils avaient pas tellement
eu le temps d'expliquer mais pourtant et
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs la gauche
récemment opposé
de sièges absolument à cause de ça en
reparler mais moi je peux le faire
évidemment c'est l'avantage on sait que
notre protection sociale le gros défaut
de peser uniquement sur le travail alors
qu'elle protège tout le monde et du coup
elle protège elle est très très lourde
sur le travail et ça crée pour un fiscal
au social terrible avec la différence
entre le super brut que paye
l'entreprise et le net net qui reste
dans la poche du salarié après son
travail pour augmenter le net d'un coup
il suffirait d'augmenter la TVA et ce
qui est formidable c'est que la TVA avec
suffirait de quelques points pour
arriver à alléger considérablement la
salaire net créé en 1954 la TVA donc 70
ans après reste toujours une idée
d'avenir alors un parti pris vous a
convaincu d'un mot de grandes
consolera avec le fait que une invention
française ait été mondialement
élargi adopté on verra si l'infus ou pas
dans le débat public Olivier merci
pour persévérer Isabelle on va parler du
dictateur Ramzan Kadirov les rumeurs
circulent ils seraient malade empoisonné
et il aurait disparu qu'en est-il
véritablement alors c'est encore c'est
un mystère de plus dans dans les
coulisses du dans le jeu d'ombres qui
agite les coulisses du Kremlin depuis
tentative de putsch divine Prigogine et
depuis aussi son assassinat alors
qu'est-ce qui se passe ce qui se passe
il y a une certitude c'est que ramsane
kadirof s'est fait donc le dictateur
tchétchène c'est fait très très discret
ces derniers temps il a quasiment
disparu de la scène publique certains
disent qu'il a été malade qu'il est très
malade qu'il est dans un hôpital à
Moscou qui leur était greffé d'un rein
et que le le l'opération aurait été
rejetée on a vu des grosses voitures
très luxueuses immatricules à grosnie
circulait près de l'hôpital central de
de Moscou pardon certains disent qu'il
est dans le coma d'autres qu'il a été
empoisonné et certains évoquent même la
possibilité de sa mort et en avancerait
pas tout de suite parce qu'il faudrait
comme à l'époque de certains dictateurs
préparés en tout cas il a une réponse
extrêmement
qui est-il on dit que c'est le valet de
Poutine alors c'est le valet de Poutine
c'est l'exécuteur des bases c'est un
homme extrêmement brutal un culte qui a
été mis au pouvoir en 2007 par Vladimir
Poutine pour à la place de son père qui
avait été assassiné pour essayer de ne
pas pacifier mais de normaliser la
Tchétchénie qui avait été en fait du
soumettre à la Russie après deux guerres
extrêmement cruelle il est très connu
pour sa britalité il adore les tortures
à l'électricité il organise des combats
d'enfants il encourage des crimes
d'honneur contre les femmes qui ont
soi-disant une
identité une morale trop libre il est
islamiste il a instauré la charia mais
aussi la polygamie il a aussi une milice
30000 hommes qu'on appelle les
cadirovski qui font la traque dans les
rues de grossesnie aux homosexuels mais
qui donne aussi un coup de main à la
République
dans Vladimir Poutine dans sa guerre
contre l'Ukraine alors d'un mot pour
conclure vous avez vu que nous tant nous
est compté
quelle concerne conséquences pourrait
avoir sa disparition elle est avée une
vie du pouvoir qui pourra entraîner une
nouvelle déstabilisation du Caucase Nord
même si la Tchétchénie a été vaincue par
les guerres de Poutine il reste et c'est
depuis le 19e siècle comme ça en fait un
élan une volonté de ce peuple musulman
de s'extirper des grèves de Moscou et on
l'a encore vu aujourd'hui avec la
nouvelle offensive de l'Azerbaïdjan
contre l'Arménie au caramar depuis la
guerre en Ukraine on voit que tous les
murs de la maison Russie sont en train
de trembler vous êtes là pour nous
l'expliquer avec votre talent Isabelle
merci beaucoup on verra ce qu'il en est
de ces rumeurs de de disparition c'est
la fin de cette émission merci à vous
les affranchis Elsa à demain j'imagine
et merci à vous merci
l'heure en direct avec nous pour voir ou
revoir cette émission il y a les réseaux
sociaux LCP ou la chaîne Youtube de
notre chaîne très belle soirée à demain